so I feel like we should do it right
hello everyone welcome to a weekend
edition video this is Nina
so I've got an exciting package my
sister Alexandra works at a company in
California called you biome and what
they do is they they measure and track
information about you you this is kit
that you have to give them a sample and
then they send you a whole bunch of
information about yourself so I'm gonna
learn look myself and see what they have
to say so she made a quick video to
explain it in much more scientific words
than I just used so we're gonna watch it
and then we're gonna open up the package
hi hi Evan followers I'm Alexandra of
Evans sister I work at you biome which
is a microbiome testing company so we
make these kits and we just sent one to
Evan what he's gonna do open up the kit
and go to the bathroom wipe and test
take a little q-tip and then white piss
toilet paper a little to shake it up
send it back to us and we're gonna look
at all the different kinds of bacteria
that are in Evans poop and then I guess
yeah he's gonna do this experiment and
we're gonna see how it goes
have fun okay open this
hello of congratulations thank you so
much for joining that you biome so as
I'm looking at this I see options here
nose skin genitals mouth and gut I think
I'm doing good
so this is to send it back the address
is on here it's cool
that's good this is my spare tube used
to replace a tube if you make a mistake
or to submit an additional sample oh
these are the swabs this is what I use
the swab off oh cool look at that it's
like this liquid stuff
it says gut and there's this liquid
inside
well Elsa says to follow instructions
we're just in your kit and you buy uncom
I feel like I know what I should do like
I'm supposed to go to the bathroom swap
with this take a piece put it in here
and the mainland in here and I'm not
usually one to follow instructions like
one two three
I'm not usually good at that but it's
fun my sister so I feel like we should
do it right okay before you get started
create an account and activate your kit
register dot you bio.com
using the kid ID on the box
if you have long hair put it in a
ponytail or pin it back away from your
ears open the section five top down on
the sample kit where won't get dirty
open the sterile swab wedding wonderful
don't use regular water open this fall
by twisting the top of the package you
to dip the swab into the sterile swab
wedding one grab either the left or
right here just above the earlobe and
pull it away from the side of your head
it helps to use the head opposite the
year for example left hand pulls right
here with your other hand swap the skin
where your bow connects your neck behind
their digital time be sure to fill out
the online sample questionnaire to tell
us how you collected your Champa State
the swab into the sample collection vial
stir vigorously but don't spot for one
minute make sure the top of the sample
collection vial is tightly sealed
vigorously shake the CFI out for one man
this process helps break down the south
start up the DNA place the tightly
closed file in the inner eternity club
when you've collected all of your
sandles seal the inter-korean envelope
placing the bubble mailer envelope and
ship it back to you by what I learned
from that video is I need to go to the
bathroom counter and switch all the way
that stuff off the top okay so yeah but
now so I'm shaking it I got a shaking
for a minute I was successful in my
quest I didn't wash my hands I should
wash my hands I was so focused on this
and not intending okay so I'm gonna
shake this then wash my hands and send
this off to California and see what kind
of results again so thanks for the kid
out of tendrá for those of you watching
if you want to get your all-in tests
done you can check out you biome calm
I'll pop a link on the video and in the
description below and when I get my
results will report back and see what
we've learned about myself